welcome back to my final round recap
from the Reykjavik open
it's been a long day for me I have a lot
of stories to share from this day a lot
of stories from my final round game and
then what happened after that game but
let's get into the final game I was
playing Vitale Garbus rated 2155
and I was able to prepare a little bit
beforehand last night and this morning
and I saw that basically there were two
different openings I could expect either
a jobava London or a Smith Mora Gambit
and when he played the E4 on move one I
knew to expect Pawn to D4 on move two
and this is a Smith Mora now I should
note uh when the game started he was not
at the board he actually showed up about
10 11 minutes late we can see from the
timestamps here so I had some small time
odds but
um in the opening phase we were both
prepared for the first several moves uh
C3 and I decided to accept the Gambit
last night I was studying a lot of Smith
moral lines and after the position with
Knight C6 Knight F3 and E6 Bishop C4 I
decided to play something I've never
played before at least as far as I know
because usually at least an online game
like play Queen C7 and there's a pretty
famous trap called the Siberian trap
after castling Knight F6 Queen E2 and
then Knight to G4 uh this is what I
would recommend most players to play
against the Smith Mora because there's a
lot of venom for black here uh for
example if white plays H3 black is
already winning with the move Knight to
D4 and white is either losing a queen or
if takes like gets mated on H2
so I decided not to go into this line
because there are some tricks for white
instead of playing Queen E2 there's a
move Knight to B5 Queen B8 and then I
believe E5 if I'm not mistaken and it
can get very very tricky for black and I
just didn't want to
um go into a line that I've played
online before
wait did that make sense go into a line
that I've played online yeah so um I
wanted to play something a bit fresh bit
unpredictable well I did I'm kind of
embarrassed to admit this but um I was
trying to remember the alternative
approach for black against the Smith
more and I couldn't remember what I'd
seen before that I remembered some like
video content creator made a video on
the refutations to the Smith Mora so I
just typed into YouTube Smith Mora
reputation and a bunch of videos came up
and eventually I found a video uh from
molten Lee Grand Master from Australia
he had like a video series covering the
smithmore of her white but he was
talking about the most annoying line
black can play against the Smith Mora
which is Bishop to B4
then having watched the video I realized
that uh he had mentioned Sam shankland
recommended this in one of his courses
and uh then then the memory came back I
had seen this initially from some Sam
shankland it was like one of the free
chessable previews and I decided to just
learn all the lines last night except I
didn't learn all the lines as we're
gonna see because my opponent surprised
me pretty early on after castling I play
97 and in this position I was prepared
for basically three different moves I
was prepared for the mainline Queen C2
which molten recommends in his YouTube
video I was also prepared for Queen E2
which is the most common move and I was
also prepared for Knight D5 and one
extra thing I did in preparation for
this game was I was referencing all of
Mark esserman's games because he's the
world's leading experts on the Smith
Mora and I saw that he usually plays
Queen C2 but in some games he's played
Knight D5
but my opponent here play the move which
I just didn't come across before the
game Knight to B5 and I was already out
of my home prep but I knew I knew the
computer evaluation that like in the
main lines it gives about minus 0.3 for
black
so I knew that this shouldn't be the
best move but it's still really really
tricky and the idea of my B5 white is
targeting the D6 square and if I allow
Knight D6 and I have to trade off then
the queen can come in and the move that
I played in the game let me actually
hide notation here uh move that I played
was Pawn to D5
and I I took some time before playing
this I was really close to playing
Knight to G6 and just allowing the trade
it takes takes takes in Queen E7 was my
main alternative but Pawn D5 looked like
the more aggressive approach but from
here it gets really really crazy because
my opponent doesn't take and doesn't
move the bishop but rather
counter-attacks with Bishop F4
and now there's ideas of Knight C7 and
um yeah from here things get really
really messy I castle and then my
opponent goes into C7 with a knight
hitting the Rook and instead of moving
The Rook I decide to play Knight G6
counter-attacking the bishop so now both
Bishops are hanging for White and the
Knight is seemingly also a Target but
it's still really complicated because
after Bishop to G3 my Rook is still
hanging and I didn't want to move it
which gives time for white to take the
pawn on D5
so I decided to take the bishop on C4
and I had calculated most of this when I
played Knight G6 so I played Ponte C4
relatively quickly and after takes takes
my opponent goes up material white now
has a rook for Bishop and Pawn
but the reason why I went into this line
is because of my next move when I
considered my next move from a distance
I realized that okay I can probably be
applying some nice pressure against
White's position as a move Pawn to F5
and this is a really nice move because
it aims to question the bishop on G3 and
for the time being their style grade
Square for the bishop to go to of all
these chords covered Bishop C7 would
take away the only Square for the
knights and I have all these ideas of
eventually trapping the knights if I can
get an F4 and then Bishop D7 or even
Bishop A5 first and then Bishop D7 so I
thought there's very good compensation
for being down a little bit of material
and I thought in many cases I win
material back
so here my opponent took a pretty long
think
and played Pawn takes F5
and now the crazy thing and this was
very surprising to me during the game my
opponent took about 20 minutes if we see
from the time stamps he went from 57
minutes to 38 minutes maybe just below
39 minutes and after I took back he took
another really really long thing I think
he he thought for over half hour before
playing Pawn A3 yeah between two moves
he went from 57 minutes to two minutes
this was just a shock to me because I
I knew White's position is a bit
difficult but I didn't think it calls
for spending all the time I thought it's
still really complicated and why had
other options I should note like Bishop
C7 was a candidate move there was uh
Rook to D1 H4 so perhaps there is a lot
of things to consider for whites but
after my opponents got down to below
three minutes and played Pawn A3 I felt
like I'm in very good shape because I
still have 56 minutes on the clock and
it seems like white still has a lot of
issues to solve with the knight in the
corner and f4 on the horizon and I
pretty quickly here played Bishop to E7
because I have all the time to think my
phone's time too and the idea is to just
put the bishop on F6 and then have a
nice diagonal for it Target the B2 Pawn
which is potentially weak
and from here Bishop C7 was played which
looks really ugly and maybe a little bit
desperate but uh it turns out that it's
still very tricky for me and
psychologically it was actually
difficult for me to approach this
position because of course I want to
find the best moves but it's hard that
knowing that every move is going to come
pretty much instantly given my opponent
has less than 90 seconds on the clock uh
so I played the most natural move here
Rook T8 I did check briefly with the
engine after the game engine said Rook
fade is better for some like nuanced
reason but rookie 8 seemed the most
logical to me and after rookie won King
F7 basically defending my Rook so my
Bishop is no longer pinned I still want
to play Bishop F6 and then my opponent
plays Knight E5 and going for some
simplification and I was trying to like
avoid too much simplification because I
didn't want to get to a position that's
easier to play with my opponent's time
situation but I had to take and or takes
I decided to take and take and then
played Bishop to F6 and uh we're trading
a lot but I figured that the Knight is
still stuck I have initiative the pawn
is attacked on B2 uh White has to make a
choice here my opponent took I took and
when I saw this position from a distance
I thought it should be a pretty easy win
maybe not super easy but it should be a
technical win because I thought there's
no way the Knight can escape but I had
missed my opponent's resource here Rook
to C1 and I'm not quite in time to
defend the pawn like the two moves I
have to defend my C Pawn are Bishop E6
and B5 and both of those run into a fork
with Knight C7 and then I would be
losing so from here I had to figure out
how to deal with a rook attack in my
pawn and the move I initially wanted to
play was Pawn C3 which is probably the
best move the reason why I didn't play
this was because Knight C7 and then my
King has to move and then the Knight can
come back and then if I take the pawn
Rook
B1 I had a hard time assessing this
position because it seems like in many
cases the Knight will just come and win
the pawn on B2 and then I'm down the
exchange and the Knights escaped
so I wanted to keep the Knight trapped
and I went for uh not C3 but King D7
first giving away my C Pawn but then
having Bishop to E5 preventing Knight C7
also preventing Rook C7 and I'm still
trying to eventually do something like
B5 and Bishop B7 and win the Knight and
it's a very tricky position to
understand and I haven't had much time
to like analyze this with engine so it's
possible why it is somehow
like surviving and maybe even better
here but with low time on the clock my
opponent uh played Rook to C5 trying to
possibly win my afcon I moved back to F6
and then uh it's a situation where white
could take the F Pawn but then the Rook
gets misplaced and I would have King C6
and B6 to come and maybe in some cases I
can win B2 so instead of taking the F
Pawn my opponent plays Rook A5 going
after my a pawn and this was actually
another move I missed but it's very
logical because I either have to allow
white to win the a pawn or I have to
play A6 which allows the Knight to
escape and then work and then white
should be winning this
so I'm kind of writing a thin line here
and I decided to sack a pawn play King
B6 and after white takes then the rook
and Knight are still a bit stuck in the
corner I'm able to take on B2 and then
white is in a bit of a pickle here
because I do have the plan of B6 Bishop
B7 and
um
again my opponent is still living on the
increments he decided to play Pawn to A4
and then I took a bit of a think here
trying to calculate the forcing lines
and ultimately I found a line to win the
Knight by force but the resulting end
game uh turned out to be like still very
very tricky so the line I I ended up
playing was Bishop E5 forcing Rook A5
played Pawn B6
essentially forcing Rook B5 and the move
that I wanted to play first is Bishop B7
but the problem with this move is light
can sack the Knight for the pawn and
then win my F Pawn and if we got to this
position it's probably white who only
has winning chances
so instead of winning the Knight
straight away I had a nice just
defensive move here Pawn G6
and there's really no way for light to
rescue the knights uh Bishop B7 is an
Unstoppable threat A5 doesn't work
because it hangs a rook and once I play
G6 I felt like I was in control like I
felt like I'm the only one who can win
this game but it's very very close to
being in draw uh my opponent played Pawn
H4 I win the knights Knight Knight takes
B6 Bishop takes B6 and we got to a
position which is a slightly rare
imbalance with two Bishops against a
rook but white has the outside past a
pawn and the Bishops are not so great it
actually
corralling and winning the pawn
and when we got to this position
actually like before we got to this
position uh when I saw this was coming I
remembered there was a world
championship game in 2016 between Magnus
and kariakin and they had almost
identical imbalance it was uh three
pawns for each side on the king side and
the side with the Rook had outside pass
Pawn I think it was karyakan with the
past Pawn Magnus had the bishop hair and
I remember watching that game live and
it looked like Magnus was going to win
but uh he missed some like Engine line
that would have won him the game and
then ended up drawing and this I believe
was in the rapid playoff of the world
championship match
so it was all kind of vague memory and I
didn't remember like exact ideas from
that game but I remembered that this
position should be possible to win or at
least possible to apply a lot of
pressure to the opponent so going
forward from here my opponent plays Pawn
H5 and I did not of course want to take
and just ruin my structure so I started
with bishop t7 and then G3 and then I
played Bishop H6 which at first I
thought was a clever move because I'm
controlling all the squares a rook can
move to on the fifth Rank and I was
expecting my opponent to just move back
and give me the option then of taking
the pawn or I would have three on two on
the king side but then my opponent
played the move which I kind of forgot
about is he took the pawn on G6 and then
said oh no my rook and of course I
didn't want to take the Rook because if
I do there's takes takes and G7 and
white is winning so yeah I didn't want
to uh take the poison and instead of
taking the Rook I had to take the pawn
and now it's two on two on the king side
and The Rook still has to move he moved
to B4 and from here I was able to play
very low risk chess and just try and
optimize my pieces because my Bishops
are definitely not on the best squares
and I was envisioning a setup where I
got my Pawn to G4
and then Bishop on e4 and I thought this
was the first step to making progress in
the position where if I can keep all the
king side pawns defended and prevent any
liquidation with F3 then I can later
focus on trying to win the a pawn so
next few moves we're going to see black
improving the pieces I start with G5
King G2 King C5 Rook moves back and then
Bishop to C4 so I really want to get the
bishop to the long diagonal he plays
King G1 I play G4 Rook B2 Bishop A5 and
slowly but surely my Bishops are
becoming happier and happier
he's essentially forced to wait around
with the Rook I keep improving so now
the bishop has some direct relationship
with the Pawn King H2 he keeps waiting I
move my king
I find the the wooden shield for my
Bishop as xqc would call it he keeps
waiting and then I play Bishop to C3 and
the plan here it's a little bit
confusing to explain but in order to win
the pawn I can't just simply attack the
pawn with my light squared Bishop
because then that leaves my F Pawn
vulnerable and I can't easily cross a B
file because the Rook is cutting me off
so my plan was to eventually put my
Bishop on B6
of apologies for my uh my tired arrows
but if I can move my Bishop to B6 and
then walk the King around while avoiding
potential pin tactics then I thought
Someday my king can get to A5 and I can
win the pawn
and gradually I was able to carry
through with my plan he was staying on
the B file I played Bishop B6 and I
chased The Rook away from the B file and
then begin my king walk finally got to
A6 now he was trying to cut me off from
the fifth rank so I just kick away the
rook and this position goes to show the
power of the bishop hair Bishops worked
so well together controlling so many
squares now there's no more squares on
the fifth rank Rook had to move back I
moved forward with the King and then he
plays Rook C8 and this is another moment
where he can say oh no my pawn and of
course if I take the pawn on A4 he plays
Rook C4 winning the bishop so I still
had to be careful I played Bishop to B6
and there's still tactics in the
position because if he defends the pawn
with Rook C4 then that walks into the
fork along the diagonal so instead of
playing Rook C4 he played the move Rook
to B8 which ties down my king to
defending the bishop I still can't win
the pawn on the next move but I simply
played Bishop A7 and now the Rook is
attacked he doesn't really have a great
counter attack because I'm controlling
these squares still with the bishop so
my other Bishop can't be attacked he
moves back to B2
and I still can't take the pawn because
he has Rook A2 so it just goes to show
how tricky The Rook can be basically
alone in that end game against the the
king and Bishops but finally after I
play Bishop D4 he plays Rook B8 then I'm
able to take the pawn and I finally won
the pawn but this is really just the
beginning of my task to win the end game
um now I should note that
he was again getting low on time on move
40 if we can just go back to move 40 we
can see he got extra time because move
40 we each get an extra half hour
so essentially he got the extra half
hour and then he proceeded to use it all
up uh fighting in this end game and he
was back uh once I won the pawn he was
back a little minute living on the
increments and it was still a question
how do I actually win this position
because it seems like he's always going
to keep F2 defended and for the next
several moves it was a lot of
maneuvering first I had to figure out
how do I get my king back towards the
center I started with King A5 he was
essentially playing the waiting game but
I was able to cut the Rook off on the B
file brought my king in
and yeah the king returns to the center
and I realize my winning plan or at
least my attempt to win would be to get
my king somewhere like D2 or E2 and then
try and force his King to G2 and then
walk the king to E1 where I can attack
that pawn so for the next several moves
you'll see me try to do this bishop C7
Rook C8 Bishop D6 uh The Rook was very
annoying kind of sitting on the back
rink pinning and cutting off in various
directions
but slowly but surely I kept walking up
with my king and Bishop I got my king to
D3 got my Bishop to E4 so I'm using my
Bishops to shelter the king from any
checks
and after he played Rook to D7 I thought
that it's actually kind of difficult to
keep making progress here but I was able
to attack The Rook he stayed on the D
file and then I gradually moved my
Bishop to the other diagonal to try and
remove his King from F1 and after he
plays King G2 it looks like I'm able to
play King E2 but then he has his pesky
check on E7 so first I wanted to try and
misplace his rook and I start with
Bishop to B5 I was also just hoping he
would blunder some Bishop C6 if he plays
Rook D5 or Rook B7 attacking my Bishop I
uh I would win instantly but he's not
blunder his Rook he played Rook E7
cutting off like King and then I'm able
to play King D2
and he can't go back because I'm
controlling D7
he waits with rookie 6. I improve with
Bishop D3 He plays Rook D6 I play Bishop
C3
he waits with Rook to E6 and then I play
Bishop E2 and I'm finally setting up
exactly what I want is a bishop on E2
and then an eventual King on E1 and
a big issue for white here is he can't
quickly generate counter play against my
F5 Pawn because his Rook is actually
very misplaced he can't play rookie five
or Rook F6 because my Bishop Cuts him
off and uh my plan is key one and Bishop
D4
so he played the move Rook D6 I play
King E1 he moved back to E6 and then I
play Bishop D4 and at this point I
thought I was winning
uh just because it seems like there's no
way for him to
defend the athon it seems like I've I've
played a Brilliance winning technique to
to optimize both my Bishops and my king
but it turns out white can still survive
here and if you wanna maybe try and find
the way white can survive feel free to
pause the video but I'll go in and show
that white can simply wait
and when I take the pawn there's Rook E5
and I'm not able to defend my F Pawn
because my Bishop's pinned I don't have
Bishop D3 my bishop and king or Bishops
and King are a bit clumsy here and
um yeah with proper play this should be
a draw maybe I could still fight on
um the two Bishops against Rook but um
yeah if the pawns came off the board
like this it should be a draw but um I'm
very fortunate my opponents stumbled in
time pressure he did not wait with a
rook on the e-file he was already
shaking his head at this point and with
maybe just a few seconds left he played
the move Rook to H6 yeah he played this
with five seconds left
and this is a losing move because
I don't take the pawn first if I take
the pawn then maybe black is losing with
Rook H1 and I'm losing one of my Bishops
but I start with Bishop F3 check
and now the King has to move here or
here and in either case I take the pawn
um he played King G1 which actually
loses very quickly because I take the
pawn and then
black to move Force Checkmate in two
moves I play King F1 and there's no
stopping Bishop G1 checkmates
and this was move 60 and the score sheet
that we were taking notation on only
goes until move 60 so he resigned in
this position
or sorry not move 60 move 80. uh yeah
this is an 80 move game very long game
um and I have the score sheet here so we
can see that we've moved up all the
moves and the Arbiter actually came by
at some point during the game and
brought us another score sheet just in
case we my past move 80
but yeah that wasn't necessary
and it was a long long game
um this game lasted about five hours I'm
very fortunate to have Come Away with a
win uh probably should have been a draw
I think at some point when my opponent
was in time pressure at least in the
middle game he may have been better
or like around
like around this point when he played
Rook C1 we can just check with the
engine yeah white is for Choice
according to stockfish but it's still
very very tricky for both sides to play
so yeah that was the tournament
um this is the final round I finished
with six out of nine points I haven't
had a chance to check the standings or
my placing or my performance rating
do I do that in this video
I guess I can do that in this video I'll
show a few things here so if you go to
leeches.org broadcast I do apologize for
the layout uh just do control F and
Reykjavik you'll find official broadcast
and we can click results here
so the winner was grandulius with seven
and a half points a lot of the people
tied for second with seven points
including my opponent from round two who
has like on the verge of beating uh
Mustafa yelma's we had a really fun game
uh feel free to watch the the recap from
round two that was probably my most
heartbreaking game but also one of my
best games in terms of like the opening
and early middle gameplay
and then if we scroll down looks like I
tied
for 28th Place
not sure about my tie breaks
um I finished in 51st
I came in as a 61st seed
so I guess an average performance if I
click into my name I'll see my
performance rating I think
yeah we can see all my results here
uh looks like yeah I lost a bit of
rating I I was upset uh once and and
also drew a couple lower rated opponents
but overall I think I had a lot of fun
and interesting games I really hope
everyone enjoyed the Recaps the last
thing I'll say is that
content from Iceland is not over because
right after I finished this game in
round nine I was in a rush I agreed to
play in this blitz tournament at the
closing ceremony it was scheduled for
four I arrived at like 4 15 and it was
broadcast on live Icelandic National TV
and there were a lot of other like
well-known participants some of the best
players in Iceland a handful of grand
Masters along with Alexandra botez and
Anna cramling I played Alexandra in the
first round so um I will hopefully be
coming out with another video shortly
sharing footage from those games and my
thoughts and it should be fun content so
stay tuned thanks again everyone for
watching and liking and subscribing and
I'll see you guys soon